sie ist doch fast noch ein kind wie
konnte das passieren ja diese tat
schockiert ganz deutschland in
ravensburg wurde eine 62 jahre alte frau
erstochen unter tatverdacht ein erst 15
jahre altes mädchen
es sind beängstigende szenen die sich am
dienstagabend in der dunkelheit am
ravensburger bahnhof abspielen
ein gerade mal 15 jähriges mädchen
trifft auf eine 62 jährige frau
sie will ihr die handtasche und zog dann
ein messer und verletzt sie brutal am
hals jetzt kam wohl zu einem streit oder
einem handgemenge
näheres müssen die ermittlungen noch
ergeben bei dem das mädchen ein messer
zogen die frau so schwer verletzte dass
sie daran erlag trotz
reanimationsmaßnahmen hat die senioren
keine chancen stadt innerhalb kürzester
zeit all das wegen einer handtasche
die staatsanwaltschaft geht davon aus
dass die 15-jährige die raub der
handtasche nach der tat mit nimmt sie
aber dann in der nähe wieder ablegt es
soll nicht einmal etwas fehlen wichtige
hinweise liefert dann eine
überwachungskamera im bahnhofsbereich im
bereich des bahnhofs gibt es eine kamera
überwachen die bei uns gewartet haben
und den entscheidenden hinweis hat uns
ein jugendsachbearbeiter vom
polizeipräsidium gegeben der das mädchen
auf der kameraüberwachung erkannt hat
und uns auf ihre fährte gelockt hat am
mittwochnachmittag dann der zugriff
die polizei verhaftete mutmaßliche
mörderin im stadtgebiet von weingarten
ein haftrichter ordnete am donnerstag
untersuchungshaft an
das mädchen wurde am mittwochnachmittag
festgenommen sie war im stadtgebiet von
weingarten unterwegs und von
polizeikräften aufgespürt worden
sie wurde nun erst von einem haftrichter
vorgeführt und ist nun in einer
justizvollzugsanstalt
eine verbüßte mehrmonatige haftstrafe
polizeibekannt und probleme mit der
familie
nun ist das 15 jährige mädchen
tatverdächtige eines mordes
ein mutmasslicher mord bei dem eine 62
jährige frau wegen einer handtasche
sterben musste
doch was hat das mädchen zu dieser tat
gebracht unser kollege hagen stegmüller
ist vor ort mit drei weiteren bild
kollegen um herauszufinden was ist mit
dieser wahnsinnstat auf sich hat er
guten abend tagen was ist über die
15-jährige bekannten ordensburg soweit
wir wissen wurde die 15 jährige in einem
nachbarort von ravensburg in aulendorf
sie jeden beitrag schon angesprochen
wurde
sie ist streunerin bekannt schwänzte die
schule oft und entstand einer
türkischstämmigen familie die offenbar
die kontrolle über sich verloren hat
auch das jugendamt zwar immer mal wieder
bei ihnen
und dann gab es natürlich zahlreiche
straftaten über die vielleicht nachher
noch zu sprechen kommen und eben dieses
verhängnisvolle zusammentreffen gestern
am dienstagabend zudem ist ja schon gar
nicht hätte kommen dürfen
denn ab 20 uhr ist in baden württemberg
ausgangssperre
und da dürfen sich auch keine 15
jährigen mädchen mehr auf der straße
aufhalten
die täterin wurde ja direkt bei ihrer
ersten tag oder beim ersten vergehen
dann inhaftiert wie kam es dazu gibt es
nicht erst mal eigentlich so was wie
jugend erreicht wie ist die
vergangenheit von ihr bezüglich der
straftaten die sich schon begangen hat
ja das ist ja das verwunderliche
dass dieses mädchen hat bei der polizei
mehr als zehn straftaten gesammelt und
nachdem dann dermaßen viel zusammen kam
hat der richter eine haftstrafe
ausgesprochen von 14 monaten wie wir
vorhin erfahren haben von polizei und
staatsanwaltschaft absolut ungewöhnlich
weil ab 14 ist man ja erst strafmündig
normalerweise kommen dazu erstmal ein
arrest oder ein paar arbeitsstunden war
aber auch bei der ersten bei den ersten
straftaten bei den ersten zehn bis zwölf
straftaten waren auch schon ein raub
dabei ebenfalls ein gewaltdelikt und da
blieb dem richter dann offenbar nichts
mehr anderes übrig als mit einer
haftstrafe von 14 monaten auf dieses
mädchen einzuwirken und wie wir jetzt
sehen haben gesehen haben war das leider
überhaupt nichts gebracht sie ist sofort
rückfällig geworden sein opfer und
täterin hatten auf einmal keinerlei
berührungspunkte was weißt du über das
opfer es gab ist genau das eingetreten
wovor sich jeder fürchte einigt der
nachts auf die straße geht was
eigentlich selten passiert aber jetzt
hier geschehen ist die beiden kannten
sich überhaupt nicht die 62-jährige war
ein absolutes zufallsopfer
sie war einfach nur auf der war hat die
spätschicht arbeitet hier in einer
keksfabrik ein paar hundert meter weg
vom bahnhof lief zum bahnhof wollte mit
den bussen nach hause nach weingarten
und dann kam es zu diesem
zusammentreffen wissen wir dass es eine
ganz tragische geschichte ist diese frau
hat zwei kinder hat enkelkinder hat zu
hause noch ihre mutter gepflegt die muss
in den 80ern sein umfeld jetzt als
klägerin aus dann müssen jetzt ihre
kinder wissen sie jetzt um die um ihre
mutter kümmern
ein absolut unfassbares geschehen was
hier in binnen weniger sekunden macht
wurde
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren